today's new member of the day is Laurie
Heller Laurie thank you for being a
subscriber to the show thanks for
supporting the work that we do with a
few dollars or I guess as we call them
pennies pennies per day because that's
all it costs also want to say thanks to
Jennifer Valentina a longtime david
pakman show member been with us almost
five years I implore you to join Laurie
and Jennifer by signing up at wwlp.com
if you would like a discount off of a
membership get on our mailing list at
david pakman.com because Saturday is my
birthday and we are going to be sending
out just a massive massive membership
discount code which if you've been
waiting around for an opportunity to get
a really cheap membership I highly
recommend it
okay let's go to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3
0 47 50 let's go first to our caller
from the three five two area code caller
from three five two who's there
hello David this is Reese from Central
Florida hey Reese what's going on um I
thought you recently posted a poll about
Howard Schultz and how he could affect
the 2020 election yes we did apparently
he's running as a centrist independent
witch but that seems totally absurd I'm
not gonna Richie's gonna have any impact
I don't see him anyone taking him
seriously besides maybe like a few rich
people or maybe some famous celebrities
like it does yet and you feel anyone you
know I think you're right I mean I think
that
so here's the I think the most likely
scenario if we imagine like a bell curve
I think it's a single tailed curve I
think the most likely scenario is that
he just has like the the thick of the
curve is he has no impact whatsoever and
that if he were to have an impact it
would be one that is helping Donald
Trump in the end so I totally agree with
you I would love to get an answer from
him about why Starbucks coffee is so
terrible although I think I know the
answer to that but beyond that I'm not
even remotely curious yeah I don't even
fit on Twitter doesn't medicare-for-all
in America
well it is in a sense in the sense that
in the u.s. we have a completely immoral
and perverted system of healthcare in
that sense it's not an American system
right now other than the fact that
Medicare is American so so that that
kind of makes it a little thing to say
you know yeah okay thanks for the call
Rhys thanks very much